l'Hôpital Privé Parly 2 à son hôpital de
jour de cardiologie créé depuis le 15
septembre 2022 cette unité de 17 litres
prend en charge des examens de type
coronarographie ou encore
angioplastiques a reçu son 100e patient
le jeudi 13 octobre au Chesnay
Rocancourt
objectifs ayant amené à l'ouverture de
ces services d'hôpital de jour et de
permettre une fluidification du circuit
de prise en charge du patient au sein de
la clinique
de permettre aux patients de de
concentrer ces rendez-vous de prise en
charge sur une seule journée depuis
septembre l'établissement a fait
l'acquisition d'un scanner coronaire de
dernière génération un matériel
permettant une acquisition accélérée
afin d'éviter les flots liés au
mouvement des patients lors d'un examen
il est très très bon en cardiologie
puisque en un quart de seconde on arrive
à faire une acquisition sur la totalité
des coronaires c'est un examen qui est
peu invasif
qui est une valeur diagnostic très
intéressante pour pour tous les patients
de cardio l'Hôpital Privé Parly 2
accueille un service de cardiologie et
radiologie vasculaire interventionnelle
cette unité prend en charge les formes
les plus sévères d'urgence cardiologique
on a beaucoup de matériel parce que nous
on opère pas donc tout se passe en
percutanée en passant par les artères
des jambes donc on a énormément de
matériel et chaque matériel est dédié au
millimètre près qui correspond aux
artères qu'on va devoir travailler il y
a quelques années une couronne graphiste
ça faisait sur deux jours
d'hospitalisation sinon je plastique il
faut à 3-4 jours maintenant grâce à
la technicité du matériel on peut
traiter la plupart des patients en
ambulatoire ce qui permet de limiter les
durées d'hospitalisation les maladies
cardiovasculaires sont la première cause
de mortalité dans le monde et la
deuxième en France après les cancers
elles sont à l'origine d'environ 140 000
décès par an